hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play the Gray
Eagle this fantastic amnesia custom
story I am out of oil but that will not
stop me from being an idiot I will
continue down this road of destruction
that I have laid out for myself and then
I will die ok so I can't come down here
so I am going to be forced to go down
this hallway but I don't want to go down
can I carry a torch cuz I have no oil
anymore so I've literally walk you down
this way completely blind
Lukie ugly key why is it ugly oh okay
okay good idea
alright good good good good I wouldn't
either fire the frickin cannon already
hmm so I got nug leaky I won't judge you
on your appearance key I think you're
beautiful just the way you are
oh this looks good wonder how long it's
gonna last
seriously this it's got some stories
messing with me man Kirt chunk alright
we open something I'm guessing it's that
big door at the end of the hallway maybe
maybe I don't know I don't know either
way we're gonna conceal
I have oil I'm not gonna waste it though
what I'm what was I looking at
my camera bing-bong bing-bong piano is
starting to play itself was close that's
one talented ghost
it's a goo goo goo goo goo ghost okay
anyway carrying on nice lights carrying
on okay what it didn't uh why did it
open well it it open what did it open
then what did it do did it open this
door no this door was already open oh I
see I got you okay so now oh oh sorry
just hey look whispers Taylors
okay that did something well that did or
did that did I don't have a note to know
what I'm supposed to do there what am I
supposed to do there
I just light some things I don't want to
waste too much oil because I've
literally been very negligent about my
oil use okay so I don't know anything
about that but I got some failures I
like me some sailors oh good it open
this door
good good good good good good good good
good making progress hello elevated cast
six she's Staff 11 Laura cast 92
temporary 12 population 121 in the
shelter of doom got key members here and
blah blah blah okay alright so we seem
to be in trouble these guys are
apparently running from some diabolical
demon cult of some sort I don't really
know it's bad news whatever it is in
this place is flooded I don't want to go
in whoa whoa whoa loading loading
apparently okay all right okay all right
we're moving on okay
did I just spend a few hours swimming
good
why you got [ __ ] what you doing there
what you doing there friendly friendly
my friendly do I need to stack boxes to
get out of here dad it allows me okay
here's a bit of flesh which I'm gonna
use later but I'm gonna take this box
put it over here stack it up all nice
and neat and get the hell out
yes I don't want to be down there no
siree Bob
okay shadows surrounding my head why
this seriously like a really good custom
story yes fully refilled like I'm
actually surprised in how good this
custom story is or has been anyway it's
just been spooky out the wazoo
what what what what why why what was
that what was that what you tell me what
that was before I go down there okay
hey oh hi let's go buddy
man for not being a custom campaign
that's got a lot of stuff in it her full
conversion mod well hello what happened
to you what are you naked except for
your helmet doesn't make much sense
you're cool all right then all right I'm
out of here
it's so weird
why why'd I go out see the thing is it's
just the small things it's a small
subtle changes that really make you feel
paranoid when you're playing the game
like why did this go out it's suddenly
not red anymore why it's like this these
tiny things and they work so well huh hi
that's a converting blue go what the
hell was that then the body just flying
up in the air and there's a spider
seriously this is what a custom story
should be it's not about the overtly
obvious good it's about the subtle okay
all right we're fine we're fine nothing
Bad's happening we're fine you're not
fine what happened did the door just
bust down there's darkness I saw that
darkness you can't fool me darkness I
saw you the jig is up for you
seriously this is this is turning out to
be amazing if we can keep it up I'll be
very impressed can I take one of those
swords
maybe defend myself just a little bit
I'm gonna run out of oil no axe I'm
pretty good it's just like
pitch black in these hallways so and I
got dabbling
okay okay just take a little breather
here and stretch out my limbs no getting
scared by things that aren't scary okay
all righty then not bothering me I am
okay hello I'm mr. statue hi painting of
man in agony
hi mr. box hello mr. flow cycle rod why
why oh why why why why why why why
Sookie god damn it
how's nothing was it that was nothing
that was absolutely nothing you made me
panic for nothing thank you so much
douche I don't like this game huh
oh I just gave it all this game is
stupid but now I have all the things so
I'll be fine okey-dokey self-love
four-phase means square yes I can don't
tell me oh oh do I have to crank it up
first
what what wha well well why what no no
no no what the hell
of course I'm supposed to be able to use
this this way what what I'm not go in
there and wrong no it's all wrong you're
wrong your son of a [ __ ]
all right whatever I won't question it
wanted to be different
fine fine I can't like that I can't
light these charges why oh that's why no
thank you
I don't wanna drag whoever at that scene
from that other story
plug it [ __ ]
plug it plug it plug it plug it up play
up play up okay broken haha that was
that thing from the other one I don't
remember the name of it but that was a
thing a little flappy thing the weird
thing the thing that shouldn't exist
cuz it's weird it's weird that was that
thing that's a thing I saw though okay
okay
alrighty okay what is this event really
event in an 18th century castle alright
whatever I don't care
hey give me that I want it I want it I
see you're gonna break you gotta break
come on
alright fine fine then be that way I
don't need your failures I don't need
anything my eye my lantern on I'm an
idiot that's why I buy land or not have
an idiot okay boo pigs heads lovely my
favorite meal and in case you were
wondering and people still ask me this I
have no idea why but yes of course I am
going to play amnesia machine for pigs
when it comes out now that gets asked
like all the time and I have no idea why
did I do it yeah I did it what what the
hell okay weirdo I'm gonna block this so
you don't come running at me down the
hall cuz I know that's what you're gonna
do
don't do it man don't don't do it don't
do it I don't want any Alan
it's just like everything in this house
doesn't make any sense it doesn't make
any damn sense none of it makes any damn
sense
why why why the eternal burning question
that I ask in this custom story is why
why okay ah crap the lock on this one
yes okay um I got to go up through that
door that was a transition door and the
other way around I can't see a thing but
that's okay I don't need to her up save
a little bit oil here and there so that
we you've read what you saw a little bit
I knew it I knew it I knew it I knew it
ow I burnt myself Howie Howie oh there's
more than one it's not fair what can't I
go in there that's where I need to go
right why is that locked why are you a
douche huh
what's wrong with you what's wrong with
all of you girl douches maybe I didn't
get it and I need to do this again no I
can't touch him so I did it huh what do
I need to do well what's what what's
going on hello tell me your secrets
tell me something anyway can't let this
fire thank you please get some warmth in
here maybe I could climb up here maybe I
have no idea I have no idea what I'm
doing in this custom story anyone yeah
no it's not letting me okay all right
think think think i think ii think ii
thought it's gotta be some
worth doing there's got to be something
worth working on
now was that always there to summon here
baby gotta be some in here some some not
right I'm not right what are you doing
what is your what is your purpose light
some stuff up I got these I got these
these uh what tinderboxes I hardly you
know it's been so long since I actually
used tinderboxes too so all these things
are like foreign to me I don't even know
anymore I don't even know anymore can I
like that I want to light everything
just because I can
huh no okay so I'm lost I'm at a loss as
to what I'm supposed to do because far
as I know I have everything that I need
and I don't have a key unless this
douchebag wants to hand over his glove
to sort of bash down this door here I
can't get into living sector see why why
is that what about this bone damn it Ron
olive oil-poached nutters I'm screwed
I'm screwed on it I'm screwed so what
the hell the only thing that I have that
I can do is go back down here
I don't know now I'm out of oil so I
really can't see anything what the hell
was that something was there no my
mind's playing tricks on me I can't see
a bloody thing and tardies dark down
here anyway
dammit what am I supposed to be able to
do Oh No I don't know I'm lost it alone
and scared
oh my mommy well my mother also lit all
these candles and they don't give off a
damn bit of light they don't help at all
so anyway I'm gonna figure this out
off-camera and I won't get back to you
guys when I have the solution in hand so
err with me oh so patiently and you will
be richly rewarded beyond your wildest
imaginations which isn't that much so
thank you all so much for watching click
the annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video
Regina
show yourself
Wow